hello I'm Jordan Peele
once comedian and now master of horror
welcome to my home
now going to take you on a little bit of
a tour some of my favorite most horrific
weapons ever used in the silver screen
oh that's heavy what do you think of
that 2 Chainz I'm rocking one in this
chain will funk you up the hook what a
sexy weapon it's kind of a question mark
was the bad guy why does he have that
hook this one was actually given to me
by my accountant the Freddy Krueger
Freddy put this glove on his hand and he
killed children with it these blades
could talk believe it or not this glove
itself is worth over 300 this is a
collar I don't actually know what this
is this is scary and probably
historically relevant the large drill
now this I don't know what film this is
from clearly someone took a huge drill
to the head by putting this in the movie
I would go temple I would go crank crank
temple Brandon straight to the dome pop
out the other head throw some blood
[Music]
that's why I'm a horror director wrote
or actually fed that's just actually my
room
I've been Jordan Peele and I hope to
continue to be Jordan Peele goodbye
[Music]